그 원소의 행에 해당하는 고전적 상태와 열에 해당하는 고전적 상태가 있어요.
대각 원소의 경우, 그 두 고전적 상태가 같은 상태예요. 그래서 대각 원소들이
특별한 거예요. 대각 원소들을 해석하는 한 가지 방법은, 그것들이 확률이라는 거예요. 구체적으로 말하면,
우리가 설명하는 양자 상태를 가진 시스템에서 표준 기저 측정을 수행했을 때
해당 고전적 상태가 나타날 확률이에요. 반면에 비대각 원소의 경우, 그 원소의 행에 해당하는 고전적 상태와
그 원소의 열에 해당하는 다른 고전적 상태가 있어요. 아주 비공식적으로 말하면,
이 원소들은 이 두 고전적 상태가 양자 중첩 상태에 있는 정도와 그들 사이의
상대적 위상을 설명해요. 수업이 계속 진행되고 특정 예시들을 더 자세히 살펴보면 더 이해가 될 거예요.
지금 당장 세부 사항이 명확하지 않더라도 걱정하지 마세요.
이건 꽤 비공식적인 내용이고, 그냥 머릿속에 담아둘 직관적인 아이디어예요.
다음으로 밀도 행렬과 양자 상태 벡터 사이의 연결을 살펴볼 거예요. 양자 상태 벡터는 유클리드 노름이 1인 열벡터예요.
수학적 정의를 다시 떠올려 볼게요. 어떤 특정 시스템의 상태를 나타내는
양자 상태 벡터 ψ가 있다고 가정하면, 같은 양자 상태를 나타내는 밀도 행렬은
화면에 나타난 것처럼 |ψ⟩⟨ψ|로 주어져요. 명확히 말하면, ψ의 인덱스는
우리가 이야기하는 시스템의 고전적 상태와 어떤 방식으로든 대응되어 있고, 그건 밀도 행렬의 행과 열과
시스템의 고전적 상태 사이의 대응과 정확히 같아요. 시스템의 고전적 상태가 n개 있다고 상상하고,
열벡터와 행벡터를 행렬로 생각하면, |ψ⟩는 n×1 행렬이고
⟨ψ|는 1×n 행렬이에요. 그래서 곱셈을 수행하면 n×n
행렬이 나와요. 사실 이건 그 형태 자체로 항상 양의 반정치 행렬이 되고, 또한 ψ가 단위 벡터이기 때문에
트레이스도 1이 돼요. 이건 곧 더 자세히 살펴볼 거예요.
이런 형태의 밀도 행렬로 표현되는 양자 상태를 순수
상태라고 해요. 몇 가지 예시를 살펴볼게요. 먼저 이 상태를 고려해 볼게요.
이건 플러스 상태와 비슷하지만, 고전적 상태 1에 해당하는 원소가
허수예요. 켤레 전치를 계산하면 마이너스 부호가 붙는데, i의 복소 켤레가
-i이기 때문이에요. 곱셈을 하면 화면에 나타난 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 에르미트 행렬임은
보기만 해도 바로 알 수 있어요. 그리고 고유값이 하나는 1이고 하나는 0이어서
양의 반정치이고, 트레이스도 1이에요. 따라서 예상대로 밀도 행렬이에요.
비슷한 방법으로 표준 기저와 플러스/마이너스 기저에 해당하는 밀도 행렬도 계산할 수 있는데,
그 밀도 행렬들이 여기 나타나 있어요. 그리고 시리즈의 첫 번째 수업에서 아주 오래전에 등장했던
양자 상태 벡터의 예시가 하나 더 있어요. 켤레 전치를 계산하고 곱셈을 하면
여기 나타난 밀도 행렬을 얻게 돼요. 다시 한 번 에르미트 행렬이고
트레이스가 1이에요. 고유값을 계산하면, 또 다시 하나는 1이고 하나는 0임을 알 수 있어요.
그런데 이게 모든 순수 상태의 공통 특성이에요. 항상 하나의 고유값이 1이고 나머지 고유값은 모두 0이에요.
일반적으로 임의의 원소 수를 가진 완전히 임의의 양자 상태 벡터 ψ에 대해, |ψ⟩에 ⟨ψ|를 곱하면
이런 모양의 밀도 행렬을 얻어요. 특히 대각 원소들이 항상 ψ의
원소와 그 복소 켤레를 곱한 것, 즉 그 원소의 절댓값 제곱임을 알 수 있어요.
이게 트레이스가 항상 1이 된다는 걸 보여주는 한 가지 방법이에요. 또한 수업 초반에 제가 밀도 행렬의 대각 원소들이
표준 기저 측정을 수행했을 때 각 고전적 상태가 나타날 확률을 알려준다고 했던 것과도 일치해요.
그리고 마지막으로 한 가지 더 언급하면,
밀도 행렬에서는 전역 위상 문제가 없어요. 두 양자 상태는 밀도 행렬이 같을 때, 그리고 오직 그때만 동일해요.
특히, 전역 위상까지만 같은 두 양자 상태 벡터 ψ와 φ가 있다고 가정해 볼게요.
이는 둘 중 하나, 예를 들어 φ를 단위원 위의 복소수를 다른 하나에 곱한 형태로 표현할 수 있다는 의미예요.
φ의 밀도 행렬 표현을 계산하면,
전역 위상 인수가 그 복소 켤레와 곱해져서 1이 된다는 걸 알 수 있어요.
따라서 그게 사실상 사라지고, ψ에서 얻는 것과 정확히 같은 밀도 행렬이 남아요.
이건 꽤 좋은 보너스고요. 더 일반적으로, 밀도 행렬을 사용할 때는
전역 위상 동치 문제가 전혀 없어요. 이건 양자 상태를 나타내는 데
밀도 행렬 대신 양자 상태 벡터를 사용할 때 존재하는 퇴화예요. 밀도 행렬은 핵심적인 특성을 가지고 있는데,
밀도 행렬의 볼록 조합이 양자 상태의 확률적 또는 무작위 선택을 나타낸다는 거예요.
달리 말하면, 밀도 행렬은 의미 있는 방식으로 평균을 낼 수 있는데,
이건 양자 상태 벡터에서는 할 수 없는 거예요. 이를 더 자세히 설명하기 위해, 어떤 시스템의 양자 상태를 나타내는
두 밀도 행렬 ρ와 σ가 있는 상황에서 시작해 볼게요. 0과 1 사이의 어떤 p에 대해
시스템이 확률 p로 상태 ρ에 준비되고, 그 외에는
상태 σ에 준비된다고 상상해 볼게요. 예를 들어 p가 1/2일 수도 있어요.
그러면 누군가가 공정한 동전을 던져서 앞면이 나오면 시스템을
상태 ρ로 남기는 어떤 과정을 수행하고, 뒷면이 나오면 시스템을
상태 σ로 남기는 다른 과정을 수행한다고 상상해 볼 수 있어요. 이제 질문은 시스템의 상태가 무엇인가인데,
명확히 말하면, 어떤 준비가 수행되었는지에 관한 다른 정보는 무시하고
시스템만 고립시켜서 그 상태에 관심이 있는 거예요. 예를 들어, 동전이나
상태 준비를 수행한 사람의 기억에 접근할 수 없다고 상상해 보세요. 그 질문의 답은, 단순히 두 밀도